[Music]
leading pediatric organizations are
warning of a mental health crisis among
teen and young children during the
pandemic the cdc says emergency visits
for mental health issues increased 31
percent last year from ages 12 through
17. that's compared to 2019. payton
lance says he suffers from depression
which got worse amid the pandemic the
high school sophomore got help after
telling his mom kimberly about his
struggles and his plans to take his own
life last year they talked with our
syracuse new york affiliate wtvh at our
local elementary
payton came to me early in the school
year
and expressed
that he was having difficulty that he
in his words wasn't doing okay
there was like a week or two stretch
where i would just sleep all day it was
just too much
not being able to see anyone just typing
away your computer every single day like
a robot
in talking to him we found that he was
having worsening bouts of depression and
anxiety for a couple years even prior to
the pandemic but since the pandemic had
started
things had gotten very
dark
very bad for him and
he admitted that he did have a plan
that was very difficult to hear it was
very very scary
as a parent i felt like maybe i had
failed in some way that i didn't
recognize something i should have but i
realized it doesn't matter what i did or
didn't do before it just mattered what i
did going forward
get him the help he needs
support him
and
a lot of praying
and so that's what we did
dr ken duckworth chief medical officer
of the national alliance on mental
illness he joins us right now good
morning morning so how has the pandemic
made the mental health crisis among
teens worse nate has worsened the crisis
substantially if you think about the
teen years the young years getting out
socialization finding an identity these
are the core developmental tasks of
these stages of life
isolation not being safe feeling safe in
the world has made it all very much
harder so rates of depression rates of
anxiety substantially higher and
suicidal thoughts so the crisis that we
had before has been accelerated by the
pandemic need now we were telling
parents parents earlier in the show that
we will let them know the signs they
should look out for so what are some of
those signs well some of the signs are
so for so if you have a child like
peyton
and he comes to you and says here's what
i'm dealing with it will be when it's
least convenient for you you'll be
working on a project you'll be you know
it's the day before your uh tax
admissions are due stop what you're
doing because that's an affirmation of
all the love and the relationship
between you and your child when they
come to you it's a moment of tremendous
vulnerability
so i'm struggling i'm not feeling safe
that's a big moment so take advantage of
that moment if you happen to be in a
situation like not all kids vocalize not
all kids do that and that's why it's so
impressive what peyton was able to do
there's still a lot of shame there's
still a lot of a sense that you
shouldn't have this experience
these are ordinary common treatable
conditions and we just have to move past
this idea that they people have to
suffer in science i was reading that one
of the things that a parent should look
for is
losing interest in things but in
particular losing interest in friends
losing interest in friends because
remember back to the idea of development
they want to be with their friends yeah
right they're trying to find an identity
that's separate from us as much as we
might not always love that so loss of
interest in friends sleep
changes changes in grades
irritability and anger can be a sign of
depression it's not always sadness and
withdrawal
isolation is a concern
and i feel like there's a constellation
of things that are fairly non-specific
but when you start to add them up an
evaluation might be a good idea i
thought it was interesting that the
mother said which is what most parents
would say what did i do what did i not
do
so what should we do and what should we
not do well first of all it's not your
fault and i think it's hard not to feel
it it's hard not to feel it isn't it
yeah because we're so invested in doing
the right thing for our kids and we take
credit for their success wait a minute
uh but the truth is
one in four one in five and in the
pandemic even higher numbers of
teenagers are experiencing depression
anxiety and suicidal thoughts so what
are we supposed to do what are we
supposed to do right so first of all the
good and the bad yeah keep the
conversation going
it's okay to have this it's okay to be
talking about this experience
that's important to keep the
conversation going what if they say i
don't want to talk about it everything's
fine i don't want to talk about it
everything's fine so you know this is my
experience pressing straight on it
you know you look depressed you need
help
may not be your best strategy because a
person can say oh actually that's not
really where i want to so find something
that they see that you also see
i can't sleep
none of my friends want to talk to me
focus on that in the venn diagram of
what you see which is i'm worried you
might be depressed and the venn diagram
of what they can see i'm not sleeping
and my friends don't want to talk to me
focus on the purple right in the middle
and say well let's talk about the sleep
or let's talk about the friends and
let's work off of that because that
matters to you
another strategy is to get a
pediatrician involved most people love
their pediatricians right pediatricians
are basically wonderful human beings
yeah and they're the under they are
the heroes of the american mental health
system they're the one of the backbones
of the american mental health system
yeah and so say you know because you're
having trouble sleeping do you mind if
we call dr smith
like why i like dr smith well this is
part of pediatricians no for sure mental
health is a big part of pediatric work
so if they won't talk to you
see if you can get another person to
engage in the conversation and if you
get a call from a friend who's worried
about your child that's an urgent
situation take it seriously take it
seriously no doubt now i i hear you and
what i'm hearing as a parent is we need
to be hyper aware of what was going on
in the home but also it's not our fault
it's not our fault we should be hyper
aware you know it's complicated isn't it
because you have to be fully engaged no
doubt not your fault we have to go dr
kenworth thank you dr duckworth i
appreciate you so much um if you are
someone who's seeking mental health
resources you can call the national
alliance on mental illness helpline
that's
1-800-950-6264 in a crisis text nami to
741-741 we'll be right back